[موسيقى]
اليوم للاسف الوضع بغزه كارثه على كل
المستويات الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني منذ
اندلاع النزاع المسلح ب 7 اكتوبر لغايه
اليوم فرقوا على الارض عم تستجيب اليوم عم
واجهوا كثير تحديات لانه ما عندهم وصول
امن مركباتهم عم تتعرض للقصف اليوم خسرنا
متطوع بالهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني وعم نشوف
جرحه بين زملائنا وهن عم بتابعوا هذا
الامر على الارض بموضوع المستشفيات الوضع
كثير صعب لانه شفنا غالبيه المستشفيات
خرجت عن الخدمه والمراكز الصحيه اليوم
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني كان عنده
مستشفيين وحده بالشمال مستشفى القدس اللي
خرجت عن الخدمه وتم اجلاء كل الجرحه وكل
كل الطاقم الطبي وكل المسعفين
واليوم المستشفى الوحيد اللي بعده عامل هو
مستشفى الامل بخان يونس وهو عم بيش هلا
يعني زملائنا بالهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
والطوائف وكل الناس اللي نزحوا لهالمستوى
اوضاع انسانيه كثير صعبه في ظل القصف وفي
ظل عرقله عمل جمعيه الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني للاستجابه ما عندهم وقود ليقدر
يشغلوا المولدات الكهربائيه عندهم يعني عم
يعملوا ترشيد لاستهلاك الطاقه استجابه بال
الوسائل البدائيه وهيدا الشيء بحط يعني
خطر على الناس اللي هن اليوم هن بحاجه
للعلاج ولحمايتهم يعني وتامين العلاج لهم
بعد الضرر اللي صار
[موسيقى]
لهم الهدنه اتاحت فرصه لفرق الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني ليقدر يوزعوا المساع ليقدر
يوصلوا لشمال غزه يعني نحن من 7 اكتوبر
لحد الهدنه كان ما عم يدخل مساعدات لشمال
غزه فقدره الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني وصفوا
هديه المساعدات قدروا يردوا على الحاجات
الانسانيه الماسه ولكن الاحتياجات على
الارض ضخمه لانه نحن شفنا المساعدات دخلت
ومشكوره كل الدول وكل جمعيات الصليب
الاحمر اللي ساهمت ولكن هدي المساعدات
قليله لانه ما بتمثل اكثر من 10% من
الاحتياجات على الارض في عندك الغذاء في
عندك الدواء المعدات طبيه الحاجه اليوم
كبيره لمستشفيات ميدانيه على الارض شفنا
اليوم المستشفى الاماراتي في كمان موضوع
الوقود يعني اللي هو ما كان عم يدخل
بكميات كافه هيدا ما انعكس سلبا على عمل
المستشفيات نتمنى اكيد بالايام يعني
المقبله يتم زياده هديه المساعدات ويكون
في وقف ل للاعمال العدائيه ويتم السماح
الامن لكل فرق الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
وكل العاملين بالمجال الانساني يكون عندهم
وصول امن ويكونوا هم محميين ل يقدروا
يقوموا بدورهم
الانساني